yo tout le monde s'excuse aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur six aux bonnes actions 3
en fait c'est un peu iv mario 3 à la
base de jeu s'appelle sio bon et on l'a
renommé iv mario les joueurs et c'est le
seul jour où on peut mourir dans le menu
attend waterfall stocker ces partis
prêts center allez on y va
oui ok d'accord je vois le délire mais
pas de souci je m'en vais mais sans
doute mais c'est quoi ça je me méfie du
nuage non c'est bon attention aux trop
classe au nom au nom pas vite un nom
est-ce que c'est sérieux de faire des
choses comme ça dans un jeu vidéo non à
aller tu ne peux pas pas sur ce ton sur
hbo et c'est quoi ces espèces deux yeux
dans l'est dans les collines en rabotant
les gars je crois qu'on à repérer vous
avez dit de fermer les yeux sinon leur
père à plus tard bon ok ouverts les jeux
dénonce thouars en fait c'est bon c'est
nickel tout ça non mais je vous ai pas
dit je vous ai pas dit dans les autre
épisode qui les nuages sur des gros
pervers dangereux
tous les députés sont beaucoup tu
arrêtes sont beaucoup ça suffit voilà ça
on n'a pas ces nuages perpignan c'était
le lancement d'une usine de missiles
nucléaires ou quoi sa venue de jeu
s'arrête plus à parler d' aller
hop pop quai non mes amis mais c'est
possible d'esquiver ça non c'est comme
si on devait affronter bruce lee c'est
pas possible de l'esquivé hommes et aux
mères mais la chute
non mais là j'allais me plaindre mais en
fait juste nul ça m est lui mais rien du
tout quoi au moins ils sont gentils ils
ont pas mis le piège sur un espace de 2
m c salut je m'en vais bien d'autres
ciels je pense qu'en fait foi les là est
passé en dessous
merci merci à toi peut-être leur toit à
leicester au c'est aujourd'hui l'heure
de faire son testament juste avant de
mourir je vous aimé mes frères mes
soeurs adultes ac
oh mais non mais non en fait si l'on met
pas l'air méchant loup pourquoi il tue
moi je les verrais bien deux et des
sucettes quand kate walsh est non oh
merde au but en plus émettre une ligne
de casques bienvenue l'avait juste pour
qui sert à rien
m cette plante elle sert à rien mais
lady jusqu'au cou quand elle vient elle
sert à rien coucou ce qui est super
rageant dans le jeu c'est de voir la fin
où il met combien de vies 13,6 se sert à
rien fait pendant trois secondes tu as
tes chroniques qui te rappelle en fait
vous êtes nuls pantois amis que je
n'étais plus de me dire que je vais
sauter des pétards
on y retourne lui couper on retourne
weave dans la plante voilà c'est ça que
je voulais dire c'est l'histoire de
quelqu'un qui voulait réussir iv mario
nous avons enquêté sur ce phénomène
d'internet les jeux pourris qui font
rager pourvoi en exclusivité france naze
these tv vous propose
on va tenter un truc de dingue et
laiteries qui soulève direct ils te
laissent aucune chance
on va jouer tu meurs c'était un super
jeu ok maintenant qu'est ce qu'on fait
là c'est le dilemme
j'ai envie de sauter plus loin possible
en fait bon aloi faire ça cette fois
c'est la bonne
assez trop tendu de n'avoir d'autre est
ce qu'on peut fêter ça on trinque
ah ah ah c'est drôle hein assez drôle de
faire ça à messi il boxe de jeu
voyez ouais le perso il est comme ça hop
on le met devant et voilà tout ça là
c'est ce qu'il touche se c'est
l'explication de merde
et alors allez allez vous en voilà un et
tue trop quoi frein toi le petit dernier
à [ __ ] mais c'était tellement sûr mais
c'est non pas toi faisait semblant
d'aimer cette super musique allait tout
le monde me montre du doigt et se
moquent aaa aaa comme à l'école on s'est
fait homme et non mais [ __ ]
le mec qu'a fait le jury l'a fait exprès
de mettre plein bonhomme comme ça qui
passe et qu'on soit obligés d'attendre
qui passe pour pouvoir continuer le jeu
et ça c'est fait pour faire rager mais
moi je suis insensible à ça dépêche toi
tu es un câble lui c'est lui là c'est un
agent double on esquive tiens je te
refais est bon petit moment détente
alors ça ça ça sent un piège mais à
mille kilomètres
[Musique]
hélas les loups n'ont jamais dans
l'émission ça vous est arrivé alors là
j'étais en train de jouer à 4 mario et a
vu le drapeau final est en fait le mec
88 est loin d'une coulée qu'ils avaient
mis un tout autre info que le pardon
bien sûr ça me tracasse un corps et du
coup je suis mort année oh oh non mais
c'est quoi ce truc de malade
à ma plus grande déception c'est dire
que j'ai ward juste les aggrave
sa peau noire et banana et loue la
beauté la banane on va tous y ont la
banane ou est elle beaucoup attendaient
dans ce bâtiment tout fleurissent je ne
sais pas